je voulais voir ce qui se passait bien
je m'aperçois que la poussée délirante
vers le progrès automatique de la
cuisine se poursuit activement
je crois vous savez que l'homme a une
voiture pleine de gadgets
parce qu'il fut un temps où les hommes
entretenaient des danseuses de nos jours
ils entretiennent des ferrari ou de
mercedes est bien l'homme à une voiture
pleine de complications la femme se dit
a pas de raison que moi aussi j'ai pas
des complications atteint un double
carburateur dans ton moteur et ben moi
j'ai un double réfrigérateur à au
freezer à freezer je ne sais quoi et je
crois que les dames veulent d'avoir des
cuisines qui soit
fabuleusement moderne ça devient le
septième nautilus une cuisine moderne et
juste parce qu'il veut pas dire qu'on y
mange mieux vous ne pensez pas que
l'homme est attiré par toute cette
mécanique ménagères l'homme seul amuse
aussi regarder les petits moteurs et
puis ça l'intéresse de voir comment on a
pu résoudre les problèmes mécaniques
qu'il passionne enfin du moins du temps
je suis ravi que l'on est au service de
la femme des moyens si moderne de
travailler mais j'ai l'impression que
malgré tout
voyez vous depuis des milliers d'années
que l'on s'intéresse aux arts ménagers
l'outil le plus tard chine le seul outil
qui rajoute qu'il a qui épluche les
pommes de terre qui soigne les enfants
et qui sourit à son mari c'est la femme
alors n'hésitez pas acheter une femme
il existe plusieurs modèles que nous
serons heureux de vous présenter sur les
grands boulevards et les grandes avenues
de paris
acheter une part me direz des nouvelles